quattro anni fa
la mia vita è cambiata per sempre ed è
cambiata grazie a questo uno smartphone
facciamo un piccolo passo indietro tra
2007 e 2010 aveva aperto un blog blog di
informatica scrivevo articoli su
argomenti più disparati dalla open
source linux
le nuove tecnologie e per arrotondare
avevo messo su questo blog dei banner
pubblicitari e devo dire che è stata
un'esperienza incredibilmente poco
redditizia nel senso che nel giro di tre
anni avevo guadagnato poco più di 100
euro nel 2010 la situazione cambiata
il 2010 è stato l'anno del boom del
mobile
questo anche perché è stato l'anno in
cui sono apparsi i primi smartphone low
cost per la prima volta acquistare uno
smartphone era alla portata di tutti
ed era anche alla mia portata investendo
quei fantastici 100 euro guadagnati in
tre anni acquistato il mio primo
smartphone e la scelta ricaduta su
android perché è innanzitutto perché era
una piattaforma che era in grande in
grande espansione a me interessava molto
anche perché il sistema operativo
android è basato sul linguaggio java
linguaggio che io conoscevo abbastanza
bene
è inoltre una delle cose che a me
interessava di più era la possibilità di
creare applicazioni di personalizzazione
di grafica io sono un grande
appassionato di grafica e di conseguenza
la possibilità di personalizzare il
proprio telefono
a me piaceva molto e di conseguenza
nella negli ultimi mesi del 2010 dopo
aver acquistato questo smartphone
cominciato a creare le prime
applicazioni e ricordo bene il giorno in
cui ho pubblicato la mia prima
applicazione
era un applicazione appunto di
personalizzazione la carico sul sul
portale e per tre ore e meghni
disinteresse
anche qua l'obiettivo era di arrotondare
di tirare su qualche euro magari per
comprarmi una birra in più con gli amici
e il sabato dopo circa tre ore
torno sulla sul portale per verificare
se qualcuno aveva acquistato la mia
applicazione sto aspettando mi 12
acquisti e quello che scopro è che se in
tre anni di blogging avevo guadagnato
100 euro in 3 ore avevo guardato più di
150 euro e questo è stato come potete
ben immaginare sconvolgente ovviamente
mi si è manifestata in tutta la sua
potenza la grande opportunità che in
realtà non si presentava solo davanti a
me la grande opportunità che si
presentava davanti a tutti i giovani
sviluppatori e questa grande opportunità
è quella di raggiungere un pubblico
globale e di non farlo con grande
difficoltà ma direttamente
pensiamo per esempio a com'era la
situazione per un giovane sviluppatore
che avesse creato una nuova applicazione
e volesse renderla disponibile a milioni
di persone
beh aveva due strade che poteva
percorrere o quella di cercare degli
intermediari quindi per esempio delle
software house magari già strutturate e
vendere in licenza la propria
applicazione o cercare di farsi assumere
da queste società
ovviamente però avendo guadagni limitati
da questo magari appunto dalle licenze
oppure fondare una propria azienda per
non dover sottostare a intermediari ma
ovviamente c'è la difficoltà di crearsi
dei canali di comunicazione e
raggiungere milioni di persone
ovviamente prende impegno tempo e
soprattutto denaro
qual è la situazione attuale invece è la
situazione attuale che di fatto dal per
così dire veramente dal salotto di casa
nostra
noi giovani sviluppatori possiamo nel
giro non di ore il settimane mesi o anni
ma nel giro di minuti possiamo
direttamente raggiungere un pubblico
globale possiamo raggiungere milioni di
utenti
e questo è un concetto di libertà
incredibile è completamente sconvolto le
regole del gioco per il punto di vista
sulla vendita di applicazioni e appunto
sulla vendita di applicazioni secondo me
è bene dare qualche numero per capire
qual è un po la situazione
parliamo del mercato android come si è
evoluto il mercato chi sono
effettivamente le persone che comprano
applicazione quante sono queste persone
nel 2010 c'erano 70 mila applicazioni
pubblicate e 70.000 sembra un buon
numero no 70 mila applicazioni 1 passa
un intero pomeriggio per vederle tutte
su internet sul proprio sul proprio
smartphone
beh oggi sono più di un milione le
applicazioni pubblicate e cosa ci dice
questo numero ci dice che non solo gli
utenti ma anche gli sviluppatori sono
interessati a creare sempre nuovi
prodotti
il mercato è esploso nel vero senso del
termine
ma quante sono poi le persone che
comprano questi dispositivi
beh nel 2010 ogni giorno venivano
attivati 50 mila dispositivi e anche qua
50.000 un buon numero
se uno di voi dice avere 50 mila nuovi
potenziali clienti al giorno
cavoli chi non ci farebbe la firma beh
oggi sono più di un milione e mezzo i
dispositivi che vengono attivati ogni
giorno dispositivi android
se pensate a tutte le altre piattaforme
che ci sono in commercio
vi rendete conto e sono numeri
impressionanti ma ma da dove arrivano
gli acquisti cioè ok mi dite ma tu vendi
applicazioni ma chi è che le compra
beh il l'ottanta per cento del mercato
proviene ancora da stati uniti e asia
e qua c'è un aneddoto abbastanza
divertente sempre riferito i primi
giorni in cui ho messo in vendita le mie
applicazioni cioè vado da mio papà e gli
ho letto
sai che sta notte dormendo
ho guadagnato 200 euro mitchell
possibile dormendo guadagnare dormendo
invece sì perché mentre qua dormiamo
stati uniti e asia sono svegli e sono
ben contenti di comprare applicazioni e
l'italia dove si posiziona beh sul 4 per
cento del mercato globale non è molto e
potrebbe essere un numero magari anche
un pochino desolante a pensarci ma
pensiamo la in un altro modo
cosa vuol dire questo 4 per cento per un
giovane sviluppatore per uno
sviluppatore che vende le proprie
applicazioni dall italia ma di fatto
vuol dire che sta generando ricchezza
perché se solo il 4 per cento degli
acquisti viene dall'italia il 96 per
cento degli introiti vengono dall'estero
quindi di fatto sta importando ricchezza
nel nostro paese
e questo secondo me è un aspetto molto
molto interessante perché ha anche un
risvolto sulla nostra società
sul nostro paese in un momento di crisi
come questo direi che è più che
benvenuto ma il guadagno
secondo me è un aspetto importante ma
non è l'aspetto più interessante è che a
me più piace della del lavoro che faccio
la cosa che più piace del del lavoro di
sviluppo mobile è innanzitutto per
esempio la possibilità e la libertà che
questo lavoro da innanzitutto la libertà
di creare sono poche le dire sono pochi
gli ambiti dell'informatica che
consentono una libertà come il mobile
se ci pensate gli utenti fanno di tutto
con i telefoni fanno fotografie
condividerlo sui social network usano i
videogiochi li usano per il fitness c'è
veramente di tutto e di conseguenza allo
stesso modo si ha la possibilità di
creare di spaziare di dare libero sfogo
alle proprie e proprio interessi perché
sicuramente ci sarà qualcuno che sarà
interessato a quello libertà di lavorare
abbiamo appena detto che non siamo più
costretti a scendere a compromessi con
intermediare non siamo più
limitati a farci dettare le regole dagli
altri possiamo finalmente decidere noi
che cosa fare per esempio per me questo
significato lavorare come freelance e il
mio lavoro di freelance l'ho portato in
tale garden talen garden è uno spazio di
coworking in cui altri giovani
sviluppatori designer come me mettono in
condivisione la propria professionalità
per crescere l'uno con l'altro e il
mobile è sicuramente uno dei pilastri su
cui si poggia questo tipo di attività
senza al mobile nel mondo dell'online
commerce questo non sarebbe possibile
quindi libertà di lavorare libertà di
creare che cosa significa beh significa
anche avere libertà di sperimentare e
questa secondo me è una cosa fantastica
questo che vedete nelle immagini era il
primo prototipo di google glass che sono
l'oggetto che indosso in questo momento
libertà di sperimentare vuol dire anche
libertà di provare cose nuove di non
avere paura di essere limitati in quello
che si fa nel proprio lavoro in un
piccolo mondo ma è un mondo in un
incredibile espansione la tecnologia sta
evolvendo con una velocità
impressionante e il mondo del mobile
consente di cavalcare questo questa
crescita e di sperimentare cose nuove di
creare nuovi prodotti di esplorare nuove
vie e penso che siano pochi i lavori che
ci consentono di fare questo di
consentono di farlo da soli quindi lo
sviluppo mobile consente di avere un
impatto globale di raggiungere milioni
di persone senza intermediari da soli da
da casa propria addirittura consente di
essere creativi consente di poter dare
spazio alle proprie passioni e di
infondere nel proprio lavoro
i propri desideri e le proprie
aspirazioni e consente di essere
indipendenti indipendenti dalle
costrizioni lavorative indipendenti
da condizioni che vengono poste e
indipendenti da un punto di vista
lavorativo
da un punto di vista creativo e da un
punto di vista di sperimentazione
consente di essere indipendenti e liberi
infatti la frase che io voglio
condividere con voi che la tecnologia di
fatto veicola la libertà e questa
secondo me è un'idea che vale la pena
condivide
grazie